um for you do you remember the last real
job you had
I think I worked at Amazon
how long were you there how long was
Jeff Bezos uh underpaying you oh God
right like three four months
what's the longest gig you had prior to
being a rapper because that's not very
long three or four months yeah
uh probably like six seven months where
was that at
I was at Hollister
you were selling Hollister jeans yeah
holy White Boy [__]
they recruited me actually it's crazy it
was when I was like in high school like
we used to like there was like a
Hollister and Abercrombie and we used to
like [__] hate the kids
see I went to school with the white kids
so that's what I started like with the
whites yeah with the whites like in high
school it's still like that's why I
started going to school so you you went
to school with the whites yeah yeah
Jonathan whites
I mean you know what I'm trying to say I
mean you worked at [__] Hollister
there's not a wider place to work
there just isn't
you right you could you could have told
me you worked at at the [__] what's
what's the Pro Bass Shop a lot less
white than Hollister um there's like
country like I mean yeah
there's probably some rednecks over
there in Tennessee definitely yeah
there's a lot of them what what kind of
Dwights were you with if if they weren't
redneck what kind were they that was I
just want to give it to the
classification of caucasians here let's
break it down
that was kind of like the hippies like
they smoked weed like nice I really give
a [__] about school they always chilling
and stuff so you were there with my
cousin real artsy
did they did they did you do mushrooms
with these kids I didn't start doing
mushrooms like a couple years ago but I
did smoke with them nice yeah so you
were like this is like a white high
school it went like it was a lot like it
was white it was a lot of black people
tools a lot of like
Asian people there too so shout out
today I didn't know there was ages I
thought we just had them in Cali and in
New York yeah certain parts yeah like a
lot of Indians
so yeah which kind of Indians though the
ones from Asia I'm from Arizona and so
all of my friends who are native
American they're like Navajo yeah and
then there's Indians yeah from from
India yeah yeah yeah gotta specify yeah
you know what I mean Indian food is
great have you had it haven't we gotta
have some Indian food would you
recommend uh what's it Curry
we had a curry yeah that's really all I
had it's it's like the most basic [__]
[__] you could say yeah okay it'd be
like if somebody said you should try
American food and they'd be like yeah
have a cheeseburger okay yeah no [__]
yeah that's all I had